هناك شيء واحد تحتاج إلى معرفته عندما تحدث الملك
وولي العهد عندما
ألقوا كلمات الرجال الآخرين
اليوم ، وهو تكرار نفس الرسالة
التي تنص على أنه سيتم تحقيق العدالة
وسيتم إجراء التحقيق
بالاشتراك مع الأتراك ، وهو ما
يجب أن يكون مطمئنًا للغاية.  كانت هناك
مكالمة هاتفية بين ولي العهد الأمير
محمد بن سلمان والرئيس الديوان الجوي ،
هل يقدم هذا نقطة تحول
حيث لا تكون الحرب الكلامية ولكنها في الواقع
فرصة للعمل معًا في
قضية كيكوتشي حقيقة أن هناك
حوارًا بين الحكومتين.
على كلا الجانبين أن
يمنح بقية العالم تأكيدًا على
أن هذه القضية في طريقها
للحل ويجب أن نسمح
للقضايا الأخرى التي نحاول معالجتها في
هذا المؤتمر بالمضي قدمًا وأنك
تعلم رحلة التقدم والتحول
التي  المملكة تتعهد
وأن المنطقة بحاجة إلى أن تتعهد بهذا الأمر الذي
يستمر بلا هوادة. لقد أوضح الرئيس ترامب
بوضوح أنه هو  غير راضٍ عن الكيفية التي
ظهر بها هذا التحقيق من
الرياض ، كيف يمكنك إصلاح العلاقات
عندما يقترح أن هناك تسترًا مروعًا
في التحقيق وليس لدي
أدنى شك في أننا سنخرج من هذا الأمر
جيدًا
، وأعتقد أننا متحالفون مع الولايات المتحدة في
العديد من القضايا الجيوسياسية التي هي
أكبر بكثير من هذه القضية الرهيبة
التي حدثت ،
والموت المأساوي لجمال حجي في الواقع ليس
موتًا ، بل جريمة قتل نعترف أننا
نتعامل معها على هذا النحو سنكون
شفافين وأنا '  أنا متأكد من أن حلفاءنا
وأصدقائنا في الولايات المتحدة
سيتفهمون أن المملكة غير
راضية عما حدث مثل
أي شخص آخر في الواقع نحن أكثر تعاسة
لأنها شوهت اسم
المملكة ، ويمكن إعادة تشغيل خطة رؤية 2030
بعد ما حدث.  حدث خلال
العام الماضي سواء كان اعتقال فندق ريتز
كارلتون أو حتى ما رأيناه
في وفاة جمال كيكوتشي ، فهل هذا
يضر بالعلامة التجارية؟
نحن أقوياء ونحن
نمضي قدمًا ، أنا متأكد من
أننا سنخرج من هذا أقوى لدينا
مقولة مفادها أن ما لا يقتلك
يجعلك أقوى ، فنحن لسنا مهددين في أي مكان
بسبب هذا الحادث المؤسف الذي
سنقوم به  تعلم الدروس التي ستتعلمها
المنظمات المتورطة
وستتعلم الدروس وتضمن أن
فرص التكرار قريبة من لا
شيء لشيء كهذا يحدث مرة أخرى
لذا أعتقد أن الدروس المستفادة
ستنتقل عبر الحكومة والنظام
داخل المملكة العربية السعودية ولكن
سننطلق في هذا المؤتمر ، يدور جون حول
التحول الاقتصادي ،
إنه يتعلق بتجديد اقتصادنا ، إنه
يتعلق بالتنويع ، إنه يتعلق
بدولة منفتحة على الأعمال التجارية
تخلق فرصًا
لشعبها ولشركائنا في جميع أنحاء العالم